treetog Rafi is what we've been looking
at recently right and it's this idea of
taking the message right and we're gonna
put some more names on this right taking
some kind of text right and then you go
through this process of encryption right
encryption you might use something like
a cipher and what were the kinds of
ciphers we've looked at over the past
week or so
was the very first one that we learned
was the Caesar cipher right not to be
confused with this Caesar salad and it's
got some really big weaknesses right and
so there are lots of ways to overcome
that the next kind of method of
encryption we looked at was it needed a
physical P do you remember the one-time
pad
excellent give us okay you've got these
different processes that's what you do
and what you end up with and this is a
new word for you is because it's text
that's gone through a cipher we call it
cipher text okay so you have your
original message it's encrypted
and then this is what you end up with
okay now the reason why this right and
particularly the process of encryption
is a mathematicians game okay is because
text tips can be expressed numerically
right so this data here is B C's DS and
so on okay if you can turn it into
numbers then this process of encryption
can just be some kind of mathematical
function any mathematical function right
and it will lead you to and encrypt a
message but it'll be well it'd be more
numerical data because numbers you two
functions still gives you numbers okay
so therefore this is why this comes
under this comes under maths and it's
mathematicians you understand and work
all of this stuff okay now how are we
connected to this we looked at this idea
under one of our earlier topics right
beauty of mathematics and I told you
there were all different kinds of
symmetry not just you know
actual symmetry or rotational symmetry
there are lots of lots of different
kinds and here is where we're going to
look at another kind right so you've got
encryption going in this direction right
what is the opposite process called it's
called decrease you're very good right I
mean it's not that complicated
based on the name but think about this
consider this right
encryption this way decryption that way
if we are thinking about this
mathematically right if a function goes
in this direction then what is it that
goes in the opposite direction and takes
you back and we looked at this under the
under the topic of matrices right that
if you go in one direction and you want
to reverse it right it's very similar to
right if the word inverse good so if you
go in one direction with a function you
can go in the opposite direction with
its inverse function okay so this is
really really simple an idea but let's
listen shore up a quick table so you can
see now this is going to work okay so
for instance if the way you're doing
your encryption okay simple simple thing
okay with that Caesar cipher right we
added we used addition to all of those
numbers right so one would attend to a
four two two five and so on okay so if
that's the mathematical function that
gives you encryption then the
mathematical function that will give you
D encryption that will reverse that
process is the inverse of addition which
of course is subtraction so that's
simple right or suppliers instead of
that as our encryption function right so
close we use multiplication I know
mathematically it's kind of trivial but
suppose you took every number and then
you multiplied it by three for instance
okay multiplication is your encryption
then your decryption function will be
its inverse namely good division okay
now there are more of these right for
instance I'll show you this under
inverse notation right if you I don't
know why you would but suppose you used
like a trig function to do your
encryption right if you did say sine of
whatever the number was like one two
three four five six nine eight nine ten
etc right well then in order to decrypt
to go from this and to come back you
would use its inverse which
very unimaginably is named sine inverse
very much like so you do this okay but
we can keep going anytime you can think
of a function right
for example if it was not just
multiplication right but if it was
multiplying by a matrix like what would
you do to get the original message back
because there is no matrix division
right but we learned there are there
there are inverse matrices right so you
would work out what the inverse matrix
is and then you multiply by that and
that should return you to your original
message okay so this idea can you see
that this kind of way of approaching
encryption is symmetrical okay if you
know what this is you'll know what the
other side is they are exactly that
they're two sides of the same coin
okay so this whole idea everything here
right this is called symmetric
cryptography
okay to give you a bit of a picture
right and I would love you to try this
picture as well if you had two people
right person a and person beep okay the
idea is that each person has like kind
of like a key right so this is this is
what a key looks like right they've got
a key and they use that key to lock up
their message right they put it in a box
and then they give it to be okay
now B to unlock the message needs to
have exactly the same key right so this
is the key right
they use that key so if I know that
you're gonna add five to everything
right that's the same as knowing I need
to subtract five in order to get back
the original message it's really the
same key right and for that reason I can
send messages back and forth using the
same cake okay and that key might be one
of these things or it might be like a
one-time pad right whatever it is you
have to have it on both ends hence the
name signature cryptography okay but
when we were looking at one-time pads we
saw that this is this is not perfect
there are big problems here right not
least of which is the fact that you've
got to get the same key to each person
right and if you are separated how do
you do that do you mail it to that well
someone can get the key right so this is
a problem and what if you're on the
Internet
what if you want to send stuff securely
how do you get the same key in both
people's hands right the short answer is
you cannot there is no way really of
securely trading keys okay so therefore
this system as um as effective as it is
cannot be used for most modern
photography okay